[Music]
hi i'm alan tudyk and i'm excited to be
filling in for leonard this week because
i get to tell you about some of my
favorite hidden movie gems all new
coming up next only on reel's channel
was that the primary buffer panel it did
seem to really does the primary buffer
battle just fall off the playground ship
for no apparent reason
looks like i thought kelly just checked
the entry companies yeah if she doesn't
give us some extra flow from the engine
room to offset the burn through this
landing is going to get pretty
interesting defying interest oh god oh
god we're all going to die that's a look
at your guest host me alan tudyk and
captain tide pants himself nathan
fillion in serenity the big budget big
screen version of joss whedon's tv
series firefly welcome back to secrets
out
nathan is the star of our next hidden
gem a critically acclaimed picture from
2006 by james gunn that many moviegoers
missed out on slither is a clever sci-fi
romp that expertly straddles the thin
line between horror and comedy it has
enough creepy gore to keep an audience
from enjoying their popcorn
slither is the story of a small town
that's invaded by an extraterrestrial
parasite that turns its residents into
zombies although the film has an alien
slash dawn of the dead feel to it make
no mistake this isn't a zombie movie
rehash it's a wholly original take on
small town horror that has a sustained
feeling of creepiness and look away gore
great
oh my god baby what happened to your
face
it's just a bee stink
i'll be all right
the cast is absent of any big name movie
stars giving it the b movie feel of the
classic horror genre it emulates and
simultaneously honors fillion gives a
top-notch performance as the town
sheriff who's made it his mission to
stop the leader of the zombie horde and
if he keeps that pattern next is going
to end up here owned by a family called
the strip meyers
i know you all are tired you're barely
seeing your families
we're going to have to go there tonight
lie low
and wait slither is director james
gunn's feature film debut he's been
successful in the past as a writer for
the remake of dawn of the dead and both
movies in the scooby-doo series but this
is the first film that i suspect looks
anything like the final product he
imagined when he first put pen to paper
or finger to keyboard or lipstick to bar
napkin
whatever the one thing that i am certain
of is that the world inside his head is
a scary but hysterical place
slither is definitely one of a kind with
a plot that's impossible to anticipate
if you want to hear more about this
creep fest stick around mr creepy
himself nathan fillion will join me to
talk about what it was like to work on
this movie and share some great behind
the scenes stories
is my interview with my buddy and
slithers nathan fillion
stopping the devil the devil appears
not now
this isn't not now shut up a little
early so we get started
quickly get uh dressed get changed and
this is what i'm wearing buddy you said
casual did you set me up so well it's a
classy show it's usually leonard
malton's show it's a classic little
mountain's here no linda martin's not
here i'm here shut up alan i swear to
god
he's usually in a better mood
this is the third time alan
wow
uh so when we get back there's gonna be
some more secrets out and possibly a
little upset nathan fillion
oh
bill
i heard you're going to get grant yeah
we uh i think i should go with you well
go honey no no bill you need to look
well not on police procedure but i'm
sure there's a heap of regulations
against taking a civilian at a stakeout
he had all those physical symptoms he
was actually peculiar thank you i was
just trying to pretend that it wasn't
happening but i can't
welcome back to secrets out i'm your
guest host alan tudyk and that was a
scene from slither featuring elizabeth
banks and my good friend and former
firefly co-star nathan fillion david has
been kind enough to join us today to
discuss his heroic part in slyther as
well as his numerous other roles in
addition to his portrayal of mao on the
tv series firefly you may know him from
the 2007 romantic comedy waitress and
from his recurring appearances on
desperate housewives
nathan
thanks for coming in thank you alan
let's go to the clip
no oh no that was mine sorry i got so
excited because you got the t you're
doing a great job can i tell you so far
you think so yeah yeah i'm really glad
you could be here slither uh one of my
favorite movies i was gonna say you came
to the premiere of slither i did come to
the premiere of slither you really
really enjoyed it i rarely like you on
film i know and that's why when i saw
this i was so shocked you barely like me
in real life
i don't know i'm warming up i'm warming
up it takes time with people it does it
does let me ask you some questions about
slither
not about slither
nathan is a butt face this is about
waitress
tell me what it was like to play the
slither all right let me ask that
question
so nathan what was it like to play the
slither
i actually i i wasn't actually this this
you mean
i was actually the sheriff
who was the slither that would be uh
michael rooker
right why didn't we get
michael rooker okay so
james gunn you weren't his first choice
but how did you come about what did you
hear
that because he told me i was he said
that's the guy
really we can't find him we're looking
everywhere what did he tell you he told
me alan why aren't you going to do it
and i said i've got other things to do
something is that's what i just learned
just now as i learned that really that's
i didn't know that well we can talk
about it with james why don't we watch a
clip from movie right here this is
featuring you the lovely lovely
elizabeth banks uh this is part of the
movie where your character tries to
rescue her from the alien parasite
intent on taking over the town excellent
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what i really liked about that
movie was it it takes those those horror
movies uh you know alien
uh small town invasion type
circumstances and and puts it in a what
would you really do
kind of a scenario what would really
happen how would these people really
react i think james gunn really nailed
it yes he did yes he did i also want to
talk about some other movies that you've
been in evidently you've done more than
just slither yes that's great
um
let me see here
most of these are blank
um
oh
ooh that's an insult here we go uh
carrie russell uh lovely lovely actress
uh you worked with her in waitress yes
uh you played the waitress
well i've been a waitress
terrible wanted that yes first of all
the outfit number two in the movie i was
more of a gynecologist i was carrie
russell carrie russell was the waitress
and i was the guy to cause you were hurt
you saw this movie too i know you did
right now you are starring in
uh dr horrible's sing-along blog which
is huge
uh it's it's not out on dvd yet but it's
going to be out on dvd you can get it on
itunes internet it's one of these new
thing on the intra web that i've heard
so much about yes uh why
wasn't i in it
dr horrible yes yes well i'm i'm now i'm
just making this up
but i think joss whedon heard you sing
that's not true you're a good singer
yes you were on broadway yes twice
yes but not for singing both times just
but not for singing right good i want to
stay on the singing
you're singing in dr horrible
how much of it was you and how much of
it was in studio
dials knobs and sweeteners it's all me
it's all me singing
i think the saving grace is is that the
character of captain hammer is so very
incredibly um
into himself and
uh cheesy and out there that
the singing doesn't have to be that
great what has to be great is the guy
singing it
look how great i am is pretty much all
i'm singing
i want to just touch a little bit um
on we did a thing called firefly and
serenity we did do that that's actually
how we became pounds until firefly until
we did firefly
yes and then firefly was a tv show that
joss whedon wrote and uh
and we did 14 episodes or something like
that and then we made a movie of it
named serenity which was uh
uh great yeah i liked it yeah me too had
a good time i liked it now here's a
question for you are they gonna make
another serenity movie now as much as i
would like for them to uh there are no
plans as of yet they're not going to say
never
right but i'm going to say no plans
nathan yes thank you for coming by
alan's been a piece of cake and a
pleasure thank you very much for having
me all right buddy i'll see you soon
uh if you haven't seen nathan's
performance in slither you can find it
on dvd we'll be right back
with more secrets out